hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la 'fuga de cerebros' desde venezuela se
agudiza por la crisis en el país el
éxodo lleva al exterior a miles de
profesionales en busca de nuevas
oportunidades sin embargo la
revalidación de títulos bloquea la
oportunidad para que algunos puedan
ejercer su profesión lejos de casa pero
su experiencia y la necesidad por
talento médico les abre las puertas en
argentina y unos 1.720 médicos
venezolanos que llegaron entre 2016 y
2017 de ellos cerca de 1300 trabajan en
su profesión y unos 250 lo hacen en
zonas rurales para conocer sus
experiencias nuestro corresponsal
detalló coso y viajó hasta la localidad
de bayauca una zona a 300 kilómetros
desde la capital del país donde viven
uno de ellos
el doctor luís torre se mueve con
soltura por el pueblo es un lugar
pequeño en el que viven menos de 800
personas y hay unas pocas calles el
tráfico me encanta que no hay
y que siempre hay unos pacientes sobre
todo los adultos que son tan tiernos tan
tiernos y 100 cuando llegamos no había
casa que no nos invitaron a comer a
probar sus costos impresionantes es un
lugar muy diferente a la venezuela
urbana que él dejó en 2017 en la capital
argentina buenos aires desde donde
partió hace más de dos años para venir
aquí a hacerse cargo de este centro de
salud rodeado de campo
él es uno de los cerca de 250 médicos
venezolanos que fueron a trabajar a
zonas rurales del país en los últimos
años los médicos argentinos
está más que demostrado que no les gusta
salir afuera a los cuales pueblos
vaya busca estuvo nueve años sin uno y
luego vinieron algunos que duraron poco
tiempo hasta que llegó el doctor torres
yo tuve un historia personal muy fea mis
padres se murieron sin asistencia médica
como no vamos a querer a esta criatura
digo yo porque él se brinda con todo él
a sus pacientes
en bayauca el doctor torres está
agradecido por cómo fue recibido y
quiere que dé su paso por el pueblo dure
lo que dure quede un recuerdo nítido que
estuvo un venezolano que hizo las cosas
bien y que hizo cambios para bien que
dejó huellas y huellas positivas
mientras tanto para profundizando los
lazos que lo unen a este lugar tan
lejano a su origen
m
en italia el gobierno aprobó el
reconocimiento del título de estudios
para que los extranjeros profesionales
de la salud puedan trabajar en las
unidades cobit de los hospitales
italianos una medida para hacer frente a
la enorme presión que está afrontando el
sistema de salud un grupo de médicos
venezolanos es de los primeros en
beneficiarse desde italia natalia
mendoza nos cuenta más como miles de
profesionales latinoamericanos del campo
sanitario danielle y pierina se han
confrontado desde su llegada al
continente europeo a una dura realidad
el no poder trabajar como médicos desde
que se fueron de venezuela desde que
llegué europa no he podido ejercer mi
profesión ha sido muy complicado el
proceso de un proceso que en todos los
países es una burocracia enorme
originarios de maracay al oeste de
caracas esta pareja de médicos cirujanos
ha logrado beneficiar de una medida
aprobada por el parlamento italiano una
autorización temporal para que los
extranjeros profesionales de la salud
trabajo
en italia durante la crisis pandémica la
esperaría que este sea el inicio de
muchas oportunidades como médico a la
puerta de entrada una ilusión que
comparten los otros miembros del grupo
de médicos venezolanos seleccionados
para trabajar en los hospitales de la
región molist en el sur de italia una
iniciativa apoyada por el vicepresidente
del senado italiano quien considera la
presencia de estos profesionales una
ayuda indispensable en este momento para
italia de un con tributo es una
contribución importante aquí hay tanta
necesidad de médicos enfermeros y
personal en salud entonces cualquier
ayuda es bienvenida que para ellos es
una buena ocasión canciones de creyente
a partir de este momento pasan a ser
empleados del sistema regional de salud
y inicialmente el contrato por un mes
van a ser contratados con exactamente
las mismas condiciones económicas de un
médico italiano
esta mañana los 18 médicos venezolanos
contratados llegan con sus maletas
listas al centro de roma entre ellos hay
cardiólogos neumólogos cirujanos y
médicos generalistas todos guiados por
una misma motivación podemos demostrar
lo que somos como profesionales y dar lo
mejor de nosotros llegó la hora de
partir inicia para ellos un viaje de la
esperanza la esperanza de lograr
construir un futuro estable en la
península italiana
en el mundo son miles los inmigrantes y
refugiados calificados que no pueden
ejercer su profesión y que cubrirían
plazas esenciales en los países de
acogida y el dato de emigración de la
semana hasta 15 años de cárcel podría
enfrentar el líder del partido la liga
en italia matteo salvini el político
será juzgado por cargos de secuestro por
su decisión de evitar que más de 100
inmigrantes a bordo del open arms
desembarcaron en el país en 2019 cuando
era ministro de interior
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]